the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski has said that the situation on
the front remains extremely acute
particularly in the Eastern Donetsk
region where Russia appears to be
stepping up an offensive well joining me
now for a closer look at what's
happening on the ground as the former
military intelligence security officer
Philip Ingram hello again to you Philip
but just talk us through uh by way of
the helpful map that we're going to put
on the screen what is happening on the
ground well taking a slightly bigger
picture if we look at belarusa and that
keeps coming into the the commentary
Russia is using Belarus as a place to
train those conscripts that we heard
been called up and to try and match them
up with pieces of equipment put them
into formations because they train them
in the units that they want to fight and
then they're taking those formations and
moving them around for this spring
offensive that we keep hearing Lots
about however
um where the fighting is happening you
the Russians are carrying out the
probing attacks around zapparesia
um artillery attacks further south in
that time Pearson and all along the the
red hatch line where the red dots are
that we can see there and probing into
the Ukrainian defenses to see if there's
any weak points that they can look at
ukrainians are doing a little bit of
probing back but they're holding the
Russians in a lot of places yeah talk us
through what's happening on the
counter-offensive well contrafensive we
keep hearing over this spring offensive
the thing that will be important is the
ground whether the ground's solid enough
for armored permissions to go through
but there's there's thinking in two
potential Russian counter-offensives and
they'll want to do this before the
ukrainians get their hands on the
western tanks and infantry fighting
vehicles that are coming in and put in
tensor-like anniversaries there's a
possibility it might be this yeah on
exactly here on so towards the end of
next month your 23rd 24th 25th of
February you might try and do something
he's moved elements of second motor
rifle division
um from belarusa that's trained into the
lashank OR blast and that gives them two
options that people are talking about to
counter to contract through one down
through velodar that we can see South of
Donetsk there and come sweeping through
that to Trump push out and capture the
rest the rest of the donets or blask
um but the other one is and there's been
fighting going on this area for the last
six months through bakmud
um and exploit any successes that he
gets through there and and just talk us
through we've been uh focusing a lot
haven't we on Bachmann the last uh the
last few weeks just remind us what what
is happening there and why it's
important well it feels like last the
last few weeks we've been talking about
back mode for over six months that's the
shocking bit of birds
um and a number of things that are
happening the Russians a few weeks ago
captured the small town of solidar to
the north with a big salt mine and that
was significant they're now attacking um
at the moment in tobacco mode itself but
but trying to attack around the South
what the trying to circle the city
um and if they can Circle the city then
they'll then try and close in and push
um any of the Ukrainian Defenders that
are in there out
um it's interesting what the ukrainians
are doing they're actually carrying out
what I would describe as a fixing
military operation so they want to hold
the Russians um along along bakmut so
that they focus as much as they can in
there um and stop them from advancing
slow them down as much as possible and
they don't mind giving a little bit of
ground away trade that space for time
that time has been used to take
Ukrainian troops out to go and get them
trained on Western tanks Western
Infinity fighting vehicles and prepare
for the ukrainians counter-offensive so
actually I think the ukrainians are
successfully holding the Russians there
the Russians are full focusing um we'll
see some potential breakthroughs in the
coming days or weeks and what is uh you
I know you keep an active track of the
number of days of this war how many days
are we now in about one day of the
10-day operation well yeah three four
nine of the tender of the 10-day
operation but I'm recalculating that
I've taken that from a number of
different sources and I actually think
we might we might have skipped 10 days
somewhere and be 10 days ahead of
ourselves so I'll recalculate that and
bring it out next time all right Philip
thank you very much indeed as ever